Speaker 1: Welcome to the show. As some of
you may know, the Olympics are being held
in Japan this year and China is involved in
a genocide against the wigger people. Now,
you might be saying, David, why why are you
telling us two seemingly unrelated facts? Japan,
Olympics, China, wigger, genocide? That makes
sense. What's the connection? Well, the connection
is that Fox News guest Morgan Ortega's on
Tuesday described the upcoming Summer Olympics
in Japan as the genocide Olympics,
apparently confusing Japan with China.
I mean, what the hell? Right. Let's take a look
at the clip. And what's even more stunning is
nobody on the panel even correct, sir? Kelly
McCann. And he's on the panel. She doesn't even
nobody corrects it. And Harris Faulkner says, wow.
Speaker 2: And around these Olympics, I like
to call them the genocide Olympics. Anyway,
I'm I'm still on the team that I'm not even
sure that we should be competing because
there is an ongoing genocide in Xinjiang.
So if they're if we are going to go to
Speaker 1: Kayleigh McEnany is actually nodding.
If you're if you're not watching
Cayley's nodding about this
Speaker 2: country, if we are going to
compete and have American athletes there
in a country that's committing a genocide,
even more important, Harris, to have the
freedom of the American flag fully represented.
Speaker 1: Wow. Says Harris Faulkner. Except
that's not what's going on. And nobody corrects
Morgan Ortega's Trump's former White House press
secretary, Kayleigh McEnany, nodding along. This
is not a minor mistake. You know which country
tends to use buckwheat noodles? This is the topic
of which country is accused of genocide against a
portion of its own population. Japan has
no involvement with the atrocities. And
in April, Japan actually raised concerns about the
Chinese treatment of the wigger Muslim minority.
Now, I saw one comment which asked, is it
possible that Morgan Ortega's is talking about
the Beijing Olympics of twenty twenty two? Or
could she just be clueless and not understand that
it's not in Japan but in China that the genocide
is taking place? Normally, when someone says these
Olympics and the Olympics start in a week, they're
not talking about some other Olympics in some
future year. I don't know. I know that English is
my second language, but that's my understanding of
what people tend to say when they say these
Olympics. And what's really crazy is that
Ortega is a political adviser, served as a State
Department spokesperson from twenty nineteen to
twenty twenty one. And she's making this mistake.
Which gets us, of course, to the next question. Do
most Fox viewers know the difference between China
and Japan politically, or do they just both sort
of sound like places that are far? That are close
to where the so-called China virus came from,
and they just sound like a lot of trouble, I
don't know, Japan, China, I'm not really sure.
Maybe this is a perfectly fine analysis on Fox
News Channel because they don't really distinguish
between these two countries. But absolutely
bizarre segment on Fox News. And of course,
there are real questions about these Olympics
taking place in Japan. The questions really relate
to the pandemic, not to the Chinese genocide of
weaker Muslims. There's also questions around
the Olympics about the role of cannabis
as a banned substance, which is considered
equivalent to performance enhancing drugs, even
though it's not a performance enhancing drug.
And by some reports, it would sort of have the
opposite effect. Anyway, the point is there's
lots of issues to discuss related to the Olympics
holding them as Japan reenters covid guidelines,
the role of certain substances in drugs, so
many things to discuss. The Japanese genocide
of wigger Muslims is not one of these things
because it's completely imaginary and fabricated